ross and i recently got the privilege to
meet a remarkable and incredible group
of women it's as
you know amazing as it gets they just
made history as the first woman ever to
be in the pit crew at the daytona 500.
take a look
please welcome brianna o'leary brie
daniels and delonda wendino hi
hi
hello hello hey what's going on oh my
gosh we're so excited to meet you bri
you broke a barrier you you're the first
black woman to change tires in nascar is
that true
yes ma'am
wow
how fast can you do it and how did you
get so good at it i would say i'm pretty
fast um one tire is coming off in less
than a second if not you know second you
know at the most and a whole piss top is
done between like 11 and 13 seconds max
whoa
so cool and brianna with brie you guys
you both made history as the first
female duo to ever pit in the daytona
500 isn't that right yeah that was us
that's amazing look at that
how did it feel
it was it was really empowering just
because me and brianna came into the
program together you know essentially
from day one
me and her were together learning
everything so to see the the fruits of
our labor in such a big stage of the
daytona 500 was just like so empowering
and so much fun and and we just couldn't
believe it and so we just try to enjoy
it the best we could
now delanda you were a soccer champion
and now the first woman um from outside
of the us to pit is that true
yes yes that's true well i play the stop
where were you where were you playing
soccer
uh paris saint-germain in france for psg
and then i got recruited to play d1 in
the u.s
for the university of miami
i mean can i ask each and every one of
you
why you got into
what you got into and what makes you
happy about it brie why did you get into
this and what does it feed you to be
honest i was playing uh basketball at
norfolk state university and i've
learned that you know once i joined the
sport you know not too many of us are
doing it you know not too many women and
you know i'm just saying that
somebody has to set the tone you know to
be that example for other women to want
to be able to join a sport you know with
very um barely any women in there so
yeah thanks to you you are changing that
i love that brianna
why did you get into this and what does
it feed you
this opportunity from the drive for
diversity program
happened to come by my university and it
was
it was kind of like a why not you know
it wasn't i didn't know what i was
getting myself into
but i just thought why not and it turns
out in the whole like grand scheme of
things
probably the most rewarding part of all
of it is is getting to hear that you
know i'm an inspiration or that little
girls now know that they can go change
tires if they want to and so that's
definitely been the coolest part of all
and look at that picture of you in the
crowd on the rail just like soaking it
in yeah and delonda
why did you decide to do this and how
does it feed you
i just wanted to have fun i joined
nascar just to see what was around it
was a new experience i was like why not
and
just going to bed at night knowing that
your badass is just so gratifying
[Applause]
i'm
grateful that you would come here
and tell your stories and we can see you
and hear you and celebrate you as we do
thank you so much
[Music]